На медико-психологічну експертизу або так званий "ідіотен-тест"
у Німеччині відправляють тих,
кого вже не вперше піймали за кермом напідпитку
або якщо водій перевищив максимально допустиму норму
штрафних пунктів - 8.
Для такої кількості може бути достатньо лише кількох порушень.
Приміром, проїзд на червоний
- це 3 штрафних очки, а обгін на пішохідному переході - 4.
Обстеження триває близько двох з половиною годин і складається з трьох етапів.
Спершу порушник має на комп’ютері пройти перевірку
на швидкість реакції та здатність концентруватися у різних умовах.
Потім - задушевна бесіда з психологом.
Про питання на цьому тесті ходять легенди.
У мережі пишуть, приміром, що під час обстеження питають,
скільки днів народження у людини
або що робити, якщо побачиш на вулиці зеленого чоловічка.
Але загалом мета цієї задушевної розмови - з'ясувати у водія,
наскільки важливі для нього права,
чи усвідомлює він свої помилки
та чи дійсно він відмовився від алкоголю або наркотиків.
Третій етап - загальний медичний огляд.
Німці бояться цього обстеження як вогню.
По-перше, потрапити в цю категорію водіїв соромно.
По-друге, через його кусючі ціни.
Вартість проходження тесту залежить від тяжкості злочину.
Приміром, водій, який має порушень на понад вісім балів,
має сплатити за таке обстеження щонайменше 347 євро.
Якщо його спіймали за кермом напідпитку - 402 євро,
а якщо він був під дією наркотиків – 554.
Також від водія можуть вимагати доказів,
що він більше не зловживає алкоголем або наркотиками.
Відповідне медичне посвідчення може коштувати
від 80 євро до 250 євро.
Окрема стаття видатків - підготовчі заняття,
без яких пройти "ідіотен-тест" майже неможливо.
Як запевняють психологи - якщо людина заздалегідь готується до іспиту,
то намагається розібратися у причинах свого зриву
та вчиться уникати таких ситуацій у майбутньому.
Усі ці витрати лягають виключно на плечі водіїв.
Загалом довкола "ідіотен-тест" у Німеччині
склалася вже ціла індустрія -
пройти  іспит допомагають адвокати, психотерапевти,
платні та безплатні групи взаємодопомоги.
Втім, зробити це вдається далеко не всім -
з першого разу "ідіотен-тест" складають  лише половина порушників.
Решта - можуть зробити це повторно.